i'm very happy to be here to
discuss this topic of courage with you
at the inaugural stoic on x military
conference
my family both biological and adoptive
includes generations of people who have
served mostly in the army but
also in some other branches as well so
this is
an occasion of some some pride for me to
actually be able to take part in this
and
hopefully it'll be useful for you as
well the topic that i'm going to talk
about
is the scope of genuine courage the way
that the stoics
understand it and the reason that we're
going to be talking about this is that
courage
is something that's easily often and to
our detriment misunderstood i think
there's perhaps
more of a danger of this in the military
and in other similar professions where
courage is genuinely
needed and we'll see that it covers a
wide ground
more than just standing up to fears but
this can be helpful for anybody in any
walk of life
i think stoicism can help us to
recognize
understand develop and deploy genuine
courage and also to avoid some
problematic
misunderstandings and before we get
started i just want to talk
very briefly about three things that
often get called stoicism because we
only want to focus on
one here so the first is what we often
call lower case s
stoicism it's not really a philosophy
it's more of a
personality trait or disposition the
stiff
upper lip not showing emotion all of
that sort of stuff
that can be okay that could be useful
but we're going to put it aside
another thing that i want to say is
actually bad
is fake stoic philosophy there's a lot
of people out there
who are capitalizing on the current
interest in stoicism
by putting stuff out there that's really
just facsimiles and reductions
of stoicism we want to try to avoid that
as well
what we want to draw upon instead is
genuine
stoic philosophy and practice where do
we get that
well if you think about what modern
stoicism is
it's an adaptation or interpretation of
ancient stoicism
and ancient stoicism is found in texts
and thinkers in books
that you need to study those are the
hallmarks those are the criterion
for anything that's going to call itself
stoicism
in the present we don't have to be
slavishly devoted to it but we do have
to be faithful to it
so what does stoicism teach well it
tells us that courage is a virtue
and you know some of the stoics actually
point out that we don't have to
study philosophy in order to grasp what
courage is
seneca in letter 120 talks about
examples or paradigms he actually uses
the word analogy as well
and these are when we see people doing
things that are courageous we're like
well that's
pretty extraordinary i want to be like
that person we're attracted to it
cicero in his works also brings up
similar examples and he cautions us
hey don't expect people to be totally
virtuous we want to have the kind of
virtue that we can relate to
you know the virtue that we see in in
our workplaces in our families
in other places as well but we can go
deeper
stoic philosophy does give us a
systematic approach
to courage and there's three things that
i want to highlight here
one of them is what courage is for
what's the point of it
what is it good for another is what
courage extends to and this is what we
call the scope of courage
the third is how courage fits in with
the other
virtues which we also need so
courage according to the stoics is
grounded not just in sort of animal
responses
and affectivity but also in our rational
human
nature in seneca's letter 120 he also
tells us that
fears need to be dealt with but cicero
goes further as does seneca and other
places
pointing out that it's not just fear but
also desire
also sadness also anger as we're going
to talk about later on that need to be
harnessed and roped in and in some cases
even
put out of the picture in on duties
cicero
talks about courage and the point of it
as an ability to achieve
tasks as involving greatness of spirit
rising above
a way of dealing with dangers and toils
so that's the function of courage let's
talk about its scope now
so cicero again is somebody very helpful
he talks about
you know two aspects having a brave and
a great spirit
one of those aspects is disdain for
everything but what is honorable or
right not yielding to other people our
own agitation of spirit or
fortune that's one aspect the other
aspect is
in that mentality to do deeds great and
beneficial
to undertake difficult and laborious
tasks even at the risk
of life so that's one presentation
arius didymus in his epitome of stoic
ethics
breaks courage down into five
sub-virtues and these are not
necessarily all of it but this is
actually a great list
he tells us that courage consists in
perseverance carteria in greek
which is a kind of enduring persisting
uh in the face of difficult things
intrepidness thara lotes which also can
be translated
as confidence facing up to what
seems but isn't actually terrible
things that scare us great heartedness
megalopsuchia
this is the rising above again acting
above what occurs
normally in worthwhile and also trivial
things
stout heartedness elbsookia not being
able to be changed or shifted once
you've actually decided
what you're going to do and then the
fifth one is very interesting it's
called
industriousness filoponia literally
a love for taking on the tough stuff
and this involves accomplishing what is
proposed without being prevented
by the toils involved so these are some
very important
aspects of courage notice two things
about this
one of these is that there's much more
emphasis
placed on doing on choosing on
actions than on feeling a certain way
the other is a person might have some
aspects
or qualities of this but not have the
whole package
and so having a breakdown like this
helps us to figure out where we need to
add in the parts that we're missing what
governs courage
what should structure it what should
orient it this is an absolutely central
point for the stoics
in letter 85 seneca stresses the
rationality
of courage he says courage is neither
rash bravado
nor thrill seeking nor love of danger
rather it is a knowledge of how to
distinguish between what is good
and bad courage he says is careful of
its own safety yet it is also very well
able to endure things
whose bad appearance is false so there's
a knowledge aspect to courage as well as
a
action aspect to it marcus aurelius at a
number of points in the meditations
adds courage to a listing of the virtues
that we ought to have
implying that these are going to be
integrated in a person of good character
what are the others he brings up justice
self-control prudence and honesty
in on duties cicero really tells us a
lot there's three key things i want to
focus on here
one is that he engages in a classically
stoic disconnect between
anger and courage it's too easy to think
that that anger
is needed in order for us to be
courageous when actually they're kind of
apart from each other
a great work on this would be seneca's
on anger where he talks about this
at considerable length second thing is
he talks about the danger of those who
have and exhibit something like courage
of falling into willfulness wanting to
have their own way
an excessive desire for preeminence to
run the show to tell everybody else
what to do for glory and he says that
this can drive people
to injustice and now this is a really
key point
courage is governed by justice he says
if courage is empty of justice
if it fights not for the common safety
but for its own advantages
it is a vice a savagery and he tells us
the stoics define courage well when they
call it the virtue that fights
on behalf of fairness so when we're
being courageous there should be an
integration with
as well as challenges by the other
key stoic virtues and perhaps by
other people who have to call us out on
our own lack of virtue
now what i've presented to you here is
not intended to provide a
comprehensive and systematic study of
the scope of courage
but hopefully it will spur you towards
thinking
more and more deeply about courage
and to turning to classic stoic texts
and thinkers
as resources thank you for your time
you